die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Freitag alles
Wichtige zur Fußball-WM hat gleich
Norbert Lehmann von mir und in Berlin
gab es heute eine Premiere
Bürgerrat im Bundestag Herr los wurden
160 Menschen ausgewählt die Empfehlungen
zur ernährungspolitik abgeben sollen
Flaute nach Corona baby boom in
Deutschland wurden 2022 so wenige Kinder
geboren wie seit fast 10 Jahren nicht
mehr
und die Suche nach dem phantomtier die
in Berliner Süden gesichtete Löwin soll
wohl doch ein Wildschwein sein glauben
die Behörden
[Musik]
die Kluft zwischen Bevölkerung und
Politik verkleinern das ist ein Ziel des
neuen bürgerrats darauf hatten sich SPD
Grüne und FDP im Koalitionsvertrag
geeinigt heute wurde es konkret das Los
entschied welche 160 Menschen dem
Bundestag ihre Sicht über Ernährung
geben im Juni hatte die
Bundestagspräsidentin 20.000 zufällig
ausgewählte Bürgerinnen und Bürger
eingeladen gut 2000 zeigten Interesse
vor der Auslosung heute hatte ein
Algorithmus ermittelt wie das Ganze ein
Spiegelbild der Gesellschaft sein kann
etwa in Bezug auf Geschlecht Alter und
Essverhalten Vegetarier und Veganer
sollen entsprechen ihrem
Bevölkerungsanteil vertreten sein mehr
von Bern Benthin
1000 Varianten hatte der Algorithmus
vorgeschlagen eine davon hat die
Bundestagspräsidentin jetzt ganz analog
ausgelost ein kompliziertes Verfahren
das ist die eins zum ersten Mal setzt
der Bundestag offiziell einen Bürgerrat
ein da werden alle jetzt gefragt du
darfst und sollst deine Meinung auch
sagen ich glaube das bringt auch wieder
ein bisschen das zusammen was uns
manchmal auch in den Debatten verloren
gegangen ist einige bürgerratskandidaten
sind für die Auslosung extra nach Berlin
gekommen
Bürgerrat ist doch eine super
Gelegenheit um die Bürger direkt zu
beteiligen wenn man so die letzten Jahre
sich anguckte corona-demonstrationen etc
das heißt wirklich wichtig ist dass man
halt auf dem Fundamenten des
Grundgesetzes arbeitet und steht und
dass man damit halt alle
Bevölkerungsschichten abholt das Thema
ist Ernährung der Rat soll über
Lebensmittelpreise Tierwohl Standards
und Konzepte gegen
Lebensmittelverschwendung diskutieren
und am Ende auch Handlungsempfehlungen
vorlegen die so heißt es fließen dann in
die Arbeit des Parlamentes ein die Linke
findet das sei zu wenig zunächst einmal
würde ich vorschlagen dass man aktuelle
Themen nimmt die die Leute bewegen wir
könnten noch mal einen Bürgerrat zum
Thema heizungsgesetz z.B machen da wäre
ich sehr interessant auf die Ergebnisse
und ich glaube das ist ganz entscheidend
ist das dann die Ergebnisse dieses
bürgerrats wirklich auch eine
Verbindlichkeit haben und dann auch vom
Bundestag von der Bundesregierung
umgesetzt werden müssen mit neuen
Formaten gegen politikverdruss ankämpfen
ich hatte die Ampel im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart und das soll jetzt der
Bürgerrat leisten die Union kritisiert
damit schrumpfe man die Bedeutung des
Bundestages die Bundesregierung
entwertet durch den Bürgerrat auch das
Parlament der Bürgerrat ist nichts
anderes als ein alibi-parlament
zusammengewürfelt durch das Los
vorgesehen sind drei Wochen entsitzungen
in Präsenz dazu noch sechs Sitzungen
digital Ende Februar dann soll der
Bürgerrat seine Beratungen abgeschlossen
haben
fragen wir Ines Trams in Berlin was ist
von dieser Art der Bürgerbeteiligung zu
halten das Ziel der Ampelkoalition ist
ja Politik und Bevölkerung wieder näher
zusammenzubringen eine Kluft zu
überbrücken Bundestagspräsidentin Bars
sagt man wolle die schweigende Mitte
hören denn nach Umfragen ist eine
Mehrheit tatsächlich derzeit nicht mehr
überzeugt vom Funktionieren unserer
Demokratie viele fühlen sich
ausgeschlossen und vielleicht könnten
bürgerräte gerade in einer so
aufgewühlten Zeit in der zahlreiche
Themen das Potenzial zur weiteren
Spaltung der Gesellschaft in sich tragen
ein Weg sein den Menschen zumindest das
Gefühl von mehr Teilhabe zu geben das
ist die Chance doch die Idee wirkt auch
die Gefahr dass das Parlament als
hilflos wahrgenommen wird der Bundestag
wenn man so will sich selber entmachtet
das wiederum könnte den Politik Verdruss
weiter verstärken die Ampelkoalition
will es nun mit einem
kompromissversuchen einem Bürgerrat der
Stadt heizungsgesetz oder Integration
Ernährung diskutieren soll ein eher
wenig polarisierendes Thema einem
Bürgerrat dessen Handlungsempfehlung
zwar in die parlamentarischen Beratung
einfließen soll aber nicht befolgt
werden muss auch das könnte die Menschen
erneut frustrieren doch würden die
Abgeordneten verpflichtet den
Empfehlungen des Rats zu folgen dann
könnte man tatsächlich von einem
nebenparlament sprechen das ganz ohne
Transparenz und Legitimation
Entscheidungen trifft
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung
in Deutschland werden wieder weniger
Kinder geboren das zeigen Daten vom
Statistischen Bundesamt
2022 kamen knapp
739.000 Babys Leben zur Welt das sind
sieben Prozent weniger als im Jahr davor
damals gab es in der Pandemie erstmal
einen Babyboom und den höchsten Wert
seit Jahrzehnten
rechnerisch bekommt eine Frau in
Deutschland
1,46 Kinder über Gründe des
Geburtenrückgangs berichtet Steffen
Wachs
gestern kam er auf die Welt Amir geboren
in einer Klinik in Hamburg in der Stadt
Sankt die Zahl der Neugeborenen
besonders stark kann ich mir ein Kind
noch leisten unter den Müttern in der
Klinik sein das immer wieder ein Thema
das einerseits die politische Lage die
wirtschaftliche Lage in Großstädten die
Situation der
wohnraumsituationen und des Mietpreises
und des Kaufpreises und natürlich auch
der kriegt der hinzukommt ich glaube das
sind alles Faktoren die Leute dazu
bewegen dass sie sagen wir kriegen
vielleicht doch weniger Kinder im
europäischen Vergleich sind die
Geburtenzahlen seit Jahrzehnten eher
niedrig obwohl inzwischen in der EU im
Mittelfeld würde Deutschland ohne
Zuwanderung schrumpfen
also damit eine Elterngeneration
zahlenmäßig ersetzt wird durch ihre
Kinder müssten etwa 2,1 Kinder je Frau
geboren werden nur 1,46 Kinder pro Frau
waren es 2022 das habe nach Studien des
Instituts für Bevölkerungsforschung mit
der corona-zeit zu tun Impfung und
Schwangerschaft da gab es viele Ängste
und Unsicherheiten viele stellten ihren
Kinderwunsch erstmal zurück der
deutliche Rückgang können aber nicht als
Trend interpretiert werden mit Corona
mit Klimakrise oder auch mit mit Ukraine
oder Inflation ist es wichtig dass
Familien Verlässlichkeit spüren dass sie
wissen ein Kita Platz ist verlässlich
Vereinbarkeit Familie und
berufsverlässlich und Kinder machen
nicht arm eine verlässliche
Familienpolitik das sei der Schlüssel
für widersteigende Geburtenraten und
dann bekommt vielleicht doch Amir noch
ein Geschwisterchen
der Krieg in der Ukraine tritt allem
Anschein nach in eine neue Phase ein
nach Angaben aus Washington wird die von
den USA gelieferte Streumunition bereits
effektiv gegen die russischen Angreifer
eingesetzt zudem rückt seit dem Aus für
das getreideabkommen zunehmend eine
Frage in den Fokus wer hat die
Vorherrschaft im Schwarzen Meer
Alexandra Vacano
irgendwo im Schwarzen Meer russische
Kriegsschiffe Proben schwimmende Ziele
zu treffen und Schiffe festzusetzen
diese Bilder veröffentlicht heute das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
zwei Boote mit Marschflugkörpern haben
einen scheinfeind angegriffen die
Schießerei war erfolgreich der
scheinfeind wurde vernichtet Droge
werden von Putins schwarz mehr Flotte
Richtung Ukraine aber auch an all die in
der Welt die Getreide abnehmen so die
Einschätzung des ukrainischen Militärs
dies ist der Versuch Russlands der
ganzen Welt die Vorherrschaft im
Schwarzen Meer zu zeigen sie
terrorisieren die Ukraine auch
wirtschaftlich
und so schlagen schon wieder russische
Raketen in Getreidelager ein in der
Hafenstadt Odessa seit vier Tagen ist
nur deshalb das Umland Hauptziel der
russischen Luftangriffe bisher fanden
diese Angriffe vor allem nachts statt
doch heute wurden Agrar Silos auch am
Vormittag beschossen das ist eine neue
Qualität und die Menschen hier müssen
damit umgehen an der Front soll die
ukrainische Armee bereits die von
Washington gelieferte und international
weit geächtete Streumunition einsetzen
wir haben erste Rückmeldung von den
Ukrainern erhalten ich würde sagen dass
sie sie angemessen nutzen dass sie sie
effektiv nutzen und dass sie tatsächlich
einen Einfluss auf Russlands
verteidigungsformationen und
verteidigungsmanöver haben und dann noch
das Putin droht jetzt Polen das Truppen
an die Grenze zu Belarus verlegen möchte
sein Land so Putin werde Belarus
schützen sollte es angegriffen werden
russische Ermittler haben den
ultra-nationalisten
Igor girkin festgenommen ihm werde
Extremismus vorgeworfen teilte seine
Frau mit der ex-geheimdienst Offizier
gilt als entschiedener Befürworter des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine doch zuletzt
hatte die russische Kriegsführung scharf
kritisiert 2014 leitete girikin den
Aufstand pro russischer Separatisten im
dornbasgebiet
übermorgen wird in Spanien gewählt
wirtschaftlich steht das Land glänzend
da starkes Wachstum niedrige Inflation
ein Beschäftigungsrekord eigentlich also
eine gute Basis für Ministerpräsident
Sanchez und seine Sozialisten doch in
Umfragen liegt die konservative
Volkspartei PP vorn es wird ein
Rechtsrock erwartet aus Madrid Thomas
Walde
der Amtsinhaber läuft an dem
umfragerückstand hinterher er verweist
auf Erfolge in der Wirtschaftspolitik
und sozialer Reformen doch Petrus
Sanchez versucht vor allem Wähler mit
der Angst vor einem Rechtsruck zu
mobilisieren das erste was PP und VOX
gemeinsam machen werden ist unsere
Rechte und Freiheiten zu beschneiden
das zielt auf die Rechtsaußen VOX
vertritt antifeministische und
nationalistische Positionen und macht
mit Übertreibungen Stimmung gegen
Zuwanderung und EU
sie sagen dass sie eine Geldstrafe von
20.000 Euro für jeden abgelehnten
illegalen Einwanderer verhängen werden
nun vielleicht lohnt es sich die zu
bezahlen es lohnt sich um unsere
Identität zu bewahren und unsere
Sicherheit
in mehreren Regionen regiert VOX mit der
Volkspartei PP und die Rechtsaußen sind
bereit Alberto Figur von der PP zum
Premierminister zu machen der sagt
lieber nichts zu seinem möglichen
Koalitionspartner sondern attackiert den
Amtsinhaber
Sanchez könnte keine Grenzen bei der
Niedertracht seines Wahlkampfs sie haben
uns beschimpft gegen uns intrigiert und
uns bedroht
in Spanien stehen sich zwei politische
Blöcke unversöhnlich gegenüber eine
politische Zusammenarbeit zwischen ihnen
scheint ausgeschlossen gut möglich also
das Vox am Ende Zünglein an der Waage
wird viele gaben ihre Stimme
sicherheitshalber ab bevor sie in den
Urlaub fuhren denn es geht um eine
Richtungsentscheidung in Spanien
sechs Wochen schulfrei ab heute sind
auch in Hessen Rheinland-Pfalz und im
Saarland Sommerferien und damit im 14
von 16 Bundesländern entsprechend voll
durften am Wochenende alle Verkehrswege
werden ob die Urlaubs hungrigen an den
Flughäfen diesmal ähnlich viel Geduld
brauchen wie letztes Jahr zeigt Isabella
wieder
der Andrang ist groß am Frankfurter
Flughafen endlich Ferien ich bin freudig
erregt ja dass ich jetzt nach Spanien
fliegen kann wir freuen uns sehr wir
haben gestern schon Vorabend Check-in
gemacht das ist ein sehr schöne
Möglichkeit die wir eigentlich immer
wählen und jetzt geht es völlig
entspannt Richtung Havanna weit entfernt
scheint das Chaos des letzten Sommers
der Flughafen hat 2000 neue Mitarbeiter
eingestellt damit es diesmal rund läuft
Tariferhöhungen von 10 bis 20% und ein
Inflationsausgleich haben viele Stellen
attraktiver gemacht und doch sind viele
Flüge zum Ferienbeginn verspätet Problem
ist aber momentan dass selbst die Leute
jetzt angestellt wurden das dauert ein
paar Monate bis die in ihre Tätigkeiten
ausgebildet werden und auch fortgebildet
werden weil es fehlen vor allem die
qualifizierten Tätigkeiten die Sie nicht
in wenigen Wochen sondern teilweise
mehreren Monaten oder mehreren Jahren
ausbilden und die sind an denen es
momentan hakt die Airlines bieten mehr
Möglichkeiten damit man das Gepäck
selbst aufgeben kann und es gibt noch
eine neue App namens smartway um ein
Zeitfenster für die Sicherheitskontrolle
zu buchen wir haben viel investiert in
Technologie es gibt beispielsweise neue
sicherheitskontrollspuren die deutlich
schneller und effizienter sind der
Check-In ist jetzt automatisiert
kinderleicht zu bedienen ist eine Menge
passiert aber so richtig herumgesprochen
hat sich das noch nicht wir kennen die
lufthansa-app und darüber geht das
leicht aber sonst kenne ich keine
anderen weiteren Apps wie das hier alles
erleichtern soll ich habe über diese App
einen Slot gebucht aber wir warten jetzt
trotzdem
etwas mehr Zeit sollte man für den
Ferienstart also mitbringen
das beliebteste Urlaubsland der
Deutschen ist neben Österreich Italien
die Tourismusbranche erwartet diesen
Sommer einen neuen Besucherrekord dort
und hat wie selten zuvor mit
Wetterextremen zu kämpfen mehr als 40
Grad Hitze in Mittel und Süditalien
schwere Unwetter mit Orkanböen im Norden
Andreas Postel berichtet
Tage so groß wie Tischtennisbälle im
norditalienischen Mantua errichtet ein
Unwetter erhebliche Schäden an und um
Mailand deckt ein Wirbelsturm ich hab im
winneto umgestürzte Bäume und
monsun-artige Regenfälle Wasser als
willkommene Erfrischung dagegen in Rom
nachdem der Hitzerekord mit 41,8 Grad
diese Woche gebrochen wurde gibt es kaum
Abkühlung für die Touristen
sehr heiß ja es ist fast schon
unerträglich als wir gestern aus dem
Flughafen rausgekommen sind haben wir
gedacht wir laufen in so eine heiße Wand
rein das war wie so ein Backofentür
aufmachen und dann
sehr warm wir waren gestern im Vatikan
und
wir waren im Kolosseum und ja ohne die
Wasserversorgung schafft man das gar
nicht auch die Reiseführer am Kolosseum
haben es nicht leicht mit dem
Beschwerden das ist einfach viel zu heiß
die Leute meckern natürlich wollen sich
aber natürlich nicht das Kolosseum
entgehen lassen deswegen ziehen Sie es
natürlich alle durch und unsere Geist
machen das natürlich auch super deswegen
mit wasserpausen und wir haben hier Gott
sei Dank die ganzen Wasserbrunnen es
geht nach der Flaute während der
corona-pandemie sind so viele Touristen
in der Ewigen Stadt wie nie zuvor der
eine Organismus verkraftet die Hitze
besser als der andere der Zivilschutz
hat deshalb in der Stadt 28
hitzestationen eingerichtet
die Menschen die meisten von ihnen
Touristen können von der Hitze richtig
krank werden und sich unwohl fühlen
Hitze im Süden Unwetterwarnungen im
Norden es sind diese extreme die Italien
momentan zu schaffen machen
in Mittelamerika macht ungewöhnliche
Dürre nicht nur den Menschen zu schaffen
sondern auch dem Welthandel der
Panamakanal ist eine Lebensader für den
wahren Verkehr zwischen Pazifik und
Atlantik er führt so wenig Wasser dass
die größten Container-Riesen schon jetzt
nicht mehr voll beladen passieren können
und wenn der Pegelstand des cartoonsees
entlang der gut 80 Kilometer langen
Route weiter sinkt könnte vorerst ganz
Schluss sein MRT wissen
es ist alles eine Frage des Gewichts so
viele Container auf einem Schiff gehen
nicht mehr durch den Panamakanal seit
Anfang Juli müssen es weniger sein
Anordnung der panamaischen Behörden weil
die Schiffe im niedrig Wasser auflaufen
könnten das hier ist der Grund der
segertun der sonst zusätzliches Wasser
für die schleusenstufen liefert trocknet
aus so eine Dürre hat der 74-Jährige
Praxis noch nie erlebt bis an sein Haus
reicht das Wasser normalerweise und die
Baumstümpfe sind sonst nie zu sehen
weil wir wissen dass dieser See den
Kanal versorgt damit die Schiffe
durchfahren können
wenn das so weitergeht ohne anhaltende
Regenfälle müsste der Kanal bald ganz
geschlossen werden durch den rund 3,5%
des Welthandels laufen bisher sind nur
die größten und schwersten Schiffe
betroffen
die haben einfach zu viel Tiefgang mehr
als 15 Meter wegen der Trockenheit
mussten wir deshalb die Fracht begrenzen
die diese Schiffe durch den Kanal
transportieren dürfen
die wichtigen flüssiggastransporte
dürfen weiter passieren aber weil
weniger Container pro Schiff mitkommen
verzögern sich jetzt schon Lieferung
wenn die Dürre anhalte so Panamas
Präsident habe die Trinkwasserversorgung
für die Menschen Vorrang vor dem
Schiffsverkehr
es wäre ein schwerer Schlag für die
Weltwirtschaft wenn die legendäre
Abkürzung durch den Regenwald die
Schleusentore schließt
er galt in den USA als Letzter der
legendären großen Entertainer Toni
Bennet jetzt ist er im Alter von 96
Jahren gestorben
[Musik]
unvergessen seine gesungene
Liebeserklärung an San Francisco mit
samtiger Stimme und Charme begeisterte
Bennet sein Publikum über Jahrzehnte im
hohen Alter hatte er an der Seite von
Lady Gaga noch mal riesen Erfolg
wenn das ein Löwe ist fresse ich einen
Besen das sagte gestern schon ein
zirkuschef nach an sich das
vermeintlichen Beweisvideos andere
Experten sahen das ganz anders also gabs
30 Stunden lang raubtieralarm in Berlin
und Brandenburg Hundertschaften der
Polizei plus Tierärzte und Jäger durch
forsteten das Gebiet heute Mittag dann
die überraschende Erkenntnis die
vermeintliche Löwin war wohl doch ein
Wildschwein Jan Meyer
erleichtert gab der Bürgermeister von
Kleinmachnow Entwarnung er zeigte sich
überzeugt dass alle Hinweise falsch
gedeutet wurden die Aufnahmen zeigen ein
einheimisches Wildschwein und keine
exotische Großkatze das ganze Drumherum
dass wir im Moment keine akute
Gefährdungslage haben und dass das sich
weil es auch in keinem einzigen Fall
bestätigt wurde wohl bei dem bei den
Videoaufnahmen aus der gestrigen Nacht
nicht um eine Löwen oder ein Raubtier
handelt gestern sah es noch so aus ein
Anwohner hatte die Begegnung mit dem
Handy gefilmt die Behörden hielten das
Video für überzeugend inzwischen haben
Experten Körperformen und Haltung des
Tieres analysiert und kamen zu dem
Schluss dass es sich keinesfalls um eine
Löwin handelt im Einsatz waren über 200
Polizisten und Feuerwehrleute die groß
angelegte Suche sei auch im Nachhinein
gerechtfertigt zu der Bürgermeister die
mögliche Bedrohung durch ein
gefährliches Raubtier sei wichtiger auch
die Anwohner zeigen Verständnis für den
teuren Fehlalarm wenn dann keiner was
macht wenn der Bürgermeister sagt okay
es wird wahrscheinlich so und so sein
und dann wird ein Kind angefallen
der wäre ich auch vorsichtig am besten
schreiben wieder groß
die Polizei rückte wieder ab am Ende
blieb viel Aufwand um nichts doch die
Verantwortlichen versichern sie würden
beim nächsten Mal genauso wieder handeln
ja jetzt zur Fußball-WM Norbert da haben
heute die Spanierinnen die meisten Tore
geschossen jawohl drei Buden in nur
sechs Minuten die Frauen aus Costa Rica
nahe zu chancenlos die Spanierinnen
haben mit dem 13.07 gleich in ihrem
ersten Spiel ein klares Ausrufezeichen
gesetzt wir wollen Weltmeister werden
die Spanierinnen Drängen von Beginn an
Richtung Tor das erste Feld hat in der
21 Minute allerdings unglücklich per
Eigentor von Costa Rica die Führung aber
mehr als verdient und die
spanierinnenwirbeln weiter zwei Minuten
später Altana bon Martin die beste
Champions League Spielerin der letzten
Saison zum 2:0 in der 27 minute dann
schon der nächste Treffer estragonales
steht gold richtig und trifft zum 3:0
entstand
wir hatten viele Chancen aber leider nur
dreimal getroffen aber wir haben
gewonnen
an der Chancenverwertung habe aber das
noch mit 46 Schüssen Richtung Torwart
Spanien aber Haus hoch überlegen und
zeigt dass da noch etwas zu erwarten ist
enttäuschender Auftritt dagegen von
Olympiasieger Kanada nur ein 0 zu 0
gegen Nigeria die Kanadierinnen harmlos
und glücklos wegen eines verschossenen
Elfmeters und im dritten Spiel des Tages
siegte die Schweiz gegen die Philippinen
die eidgenossenen taten sich schwer und
gingen erst in der 45 Minute durch einen
Standard in Führung Ramona Bachmann
verwandelte einen faul Elfmeter in der
64 minute dann der Treffer von Serena
Pio Bell zum 2:0 entstand unterm Strich
ein verdienter Sieg
ja für das deutsche Team schlägt am
Montag ab 10:30 Uhr die Stunde der
Wahrheit der erste Gegner heißt Marokko
während andere WM Teams bereits auf dem
Platz zu tun haben können ist die
deutschen Frauen noch etwas lockerer
angehen lassen
noch einmal abschalten bevor es ernst
wird
mir klar erfolgreich Fußball spielen
aber auch ein sozialen Beitrag leisten
die Spielerinnen haben sich entschieden
ein Prozent ihrer Prämien zu Spenden
zusammen mit der Initiative common goal
für mehr Teilhabe im Mädchenfußball weil
es uns glaube ich auszeichnet dass wir
über den Tellerrand hinausschauen dass
wir ein Bewusstsein haben für die Arbeit
an der Basis für Gleichberechtigung für
Chancengleichheit wieder ins Training
einsteigen konnten die Verletzten
defensivspielerinnen Marina Hegering und
Lena Oberdorf das erste Spiel werden sie
aber voraussichtlich noch aussetzen
müssen
Deutschland gegen Marokko am Montag bei
uns zu sehen der Fußball morgen beginnt
ab 7:30 Uhr
von Nordwesten her wird es morgen noch
mal unbeständig mehr zum Wetter hat
gleich als den terli Christian Sievers
begrüßt sie um 10 im heute schon mal
machen sie sich ein schönes Wochenende
bis morgen werden sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses kleine tief
hier über uns das hat heute shower Blitz
und Donner gebracht zieht allmählich
Richtung Polen ab aber wir haben eine
nordwestliche Strömung und da kommt ein
neues Tief mit vielen Wolken und neuem
Regen dazu in der ersten Nachthälfte
gibt es noch Regen und Gewitter im
Norden Blitz und Donner auch im Süden
aber das Ganze lässt allmählich nach
sowie im Westen wird es dann auch
allmählich trockener und die
Temperaturen sinken auf sieben bis acht
Grad dort und 14 Grad z.B an der Nordsee
morgen dann neue Schauer und Regen
Wolken von Nordwesten her ansonsten im
Osten trocken oder auch im Südwesten
ganz nach Syrien Richtung alten gibt es
auch Gewitter und das war höchsten
Temperaturen von 17 bis 18 Grad im
Nordwesten gut zehn Grad mehr im
Südwesten bei 27 Grad und die nächsten
Tage ja Sonntag kommen wieder Schauer
ins Land bei Werten bis 30 Grad nicht
mehr ganz so warm die Tage da drauf und
vor allem Montag dann als heftige
Schauer und Gewitter damit ein schöner
Abend